The letter's 20 years old.
After we were married and trying to have children, we couldn't have kids...
...so we adopted a son and then 11 years later, God sent Brooke to us.
Being adopted, I wanted them to know how much I loved her.
And I just thought it would be extremely precious...
...when she opened it up and read it on her wedding day.
This is a piece of my wedding dress.
And it's the letter that I wrote you.
December the 15th, 1994.
Our dear little baby Brooke.
As I write this to you, you're sleeping soundly in your baby bed.
We just want you to know how much love and happiness you brought to our family.
A precious little baby girl to Daddy and me, and a baby sister to Brian.
Before Daddy and I were married, we always said if we had a little girl,...
...she would be our little Brooke and you were our little baby Brooke.